digamos que tengo este contenedor verde
y dentro del contenedor tengo algunas
moléculas de aire ahora supongamos que
estas moléculas de aire están a cierta
temperatura y tienen una energía
cinética promedio pero todas tendrán
distintas velocidades y todas se están
moviendo hacia distintos lados ahora en
la manera en la que dibujé las moléculas
del aire ustedes pueden notar algo voy a
dibujar una línea imaginaria aquí y
bueno es una línea que no tiene un
significado estructural y realmente no
está dividiendo al contenedor es una
línea imaginaria solo la estoy usando
para visualizar el lado izquierdo y el
lado derecho de este contenedor si vemos
en el lado izquierdo tengo una mayor
concentración de mis moléculas déjame
escribirlo tengo una concentración con
sen
tras acción mayor mayor mayor y como
mides la concentración
bueno es el número de moléculas por
unidad de volumen pero en nuestro caso
sería el número de moléculas por unidad
de sección por lo que si tomamos una
sección no se se me ocurre esta sección
de aquí si nos fijamos en esta sección
de aquí observa que en este caso tengo
una dos tres cuatro cinco partículas de
aire es decir voy a tener entre cuatro
tres o cinco moléculas por sección de
este tamaño y si yo tomo una sección del
mismo tamaño de este lado observa que
voy a atrapar entre una y dos a lo más
moléculas de aire así que no voy a ser
muy preciso pero se nota o es bastante
claro que tengo mayor concentración del
lado izquierdo que del lado derecho
tengo más moléculas dibujadas por unidad
de área eso si lo pensamos en dos
dimensiones o por unidad de volumen si
lo pensamos en tres dimensiones
aquí en mi lado izquierdo voy a tener
una mayor concentración y en el lado
derecho una menor concentración así que
déjame escribirlo concentración
concentración menor
me
ahora cuando tenemos una situación como
ésta donde hay mayor concentración y
luego menor concentración decimos que
tenemos un gradiente de concentración en
este caso tengo un gradiente de
concentración y déjenme escribirlo
gradiente
diente
de concentración de
atrás
acción es decir cuando la concentración
está cambiando de alta a baja ahora qué
te parece si pensamos que es lo que va a
pasar si nuestra situación es real bueno
todas estas partículas van a estar
moviéndose una se moverán de la
izquierda a la derecha otras de derecha
a izquierda pero tenemos más partículas
en el lado izquierdo que probablemente
se moverán a la derecha que partículas
en el lado derecho que se moverán a la
izquierda recuerda todas estas se están
moviendo en distintas direcciones con
velocidades aleatorias entonces en
cualquier momento como tenemos una mayor
concentración en la izquierda se me
ocurre que ésta se va a mover hacia este
otro lado que bueno estas tendremos una
mayor probabilidad de que las moléculas
se vayan de la izquierda a la derecha
que de la derecha a la izquierda bien
ahora conforme pasa el tiempo veremos
algo así y para esto déjame ver si
traigo este otro contenedor por aquí
este otro contenedor por aquí y conforme
pasa el tiempo vamos a ver que existe
se estabiliza eso quiere decir que
después de un rato yo voy a tener a las
moléculas más o menos así cuantas
moléculas tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 y 8 19 y 20
para ser exactos tengo 20 moléculas y
aquí tengo una 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 y por aquí voy a
poner la 20 entonces si dejamos pasar
suficiente tiempo veremos que ya no
tendremos un gradiente de concentración
la concentración se volverá uniforme con
el tiempo se dibujará de nuevo mi línea
recta imaginaria por aquí la voy a
dibujar que divide a la mitad a este
recipiente observa que tendría la misma
concentración en ambos lados entonces ya
no tengo un gradiente
déjame ponerlo no tengo
radiante gran diente y otra vez no hay
nada mágico en esto en las que las
moléculas dijeran
estamos en menor concentración por aquel
lado así que vamos a movernos solo
tienes que pensar que todas ellas se
estaban moviendo aleatoriamente entonces
si tienes una mayor concentración en la
izquierda hay una mayor probabilidad de
que las partículas se muevan de
izquierda a derecha que de derecha a
izquierda incluso en esta situación las
moléculas se seguirán moviendo de
izquierda a derecha y de derecha a
izquierda pero ahora tienes el mismo
número en ambos lados en cualquier
momento dado tienen la misma
probabilidad de que las moléculas se
muevan de izquierda a derecha que de
derecha a izquierda entonces llegas a
una situación de equilibrio por lo tanto
si tomas por unidad de tiempo una
partícula no se supongamos esta se puede
mover a la derecha esta también se
podría mover a derecha esta tal vez en
podríamos ver a la derecha pero como
tienes la misma concentración en ambos
lados es igual de probable que tengas el
mismo número de parte
las que se muevan de derecha a izquierda
por ejemplo esta se me ocurre que esta
también se podría mover y esto también
yo sólo hice esto con 20 partículas que
es un número muy bajo si realmente
estuviéramos hablando de concentración
de moléculas de aire o como veremos si
pensamos en membranas celulares y en
distintos tipos de moléculas en una
solución acuosa estaríamos hablando de
más de 20 moléculas por lo que tenemos
que pensar en términos de mayores
números probabilísticos pero la
probabilidad de que se muevan de
izquierda a derecha es la misma de que
se muevan de derecha a izquierda y así
tendrás este equilibrio en nuestro caso
anterior hay más probabilidad de que se
muevan las moléculas de izquierda a
derecha que viceversa y esto es porque
las partículas se mueven de mayor a
menor concentración o bien otra manera
de pensarlo es decir lo siguiente lo que
acabamos de observar es que las
moléculas se difunden a favor del
gradiente este proceso que acabamos de
describir
la difusión así que déjenme bajar un
poco la pantalla para poder escribirlo
este proceso es lo que se conoce con el
nombre de difusión de full
sión conforme estudiamos diferentes
sistemas veremos que este proceso es muy
importante para los sistemas biológicos
y para los sistemas químicos porque este
proceso no requiere energía extra para
mover las moléculas de aquí a allá esto
sucederá probabilísticamente de manera
natural y de nuevo sin magia sólo con
tener mayor concentración en un lado hay
más probabilidad de que se mueva de
izquierda a derecha que de derecha a
izquierda y quiero dejar esto muy claro
las partículas también se pueden mover
de derecha a izquierda por ejemplo
puedes tener esta partícula de aquí
déjame cambiarle un poco la dirección
así que supongamos que este de aquí se
mueve de derecha a izquierda así que lo
voy a poner moviéndose para acá y bueno
es completamente posible que vaya en
esta dirección no es que todo se mueva
de izquierda a derecha pero existe mayor
probabilidad de que haya más partículas
que se muevan de izquierda a derecha no
sé este amigo de quien se moverá hacia
helado porque hay más cosas aquí en el
lado izquierdo recuerda que todas se
están moviendo en direcciones aleatorias
diferentes